on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored chaos
at conference as the Tory Feud of a
pensions custom benefits and just about
everything else as this trust lost
control of her party as she has the
country
tough talk on fixing Britain's illegal
migrant crisis but the Home Secretary
admits there is no quick fix
plus the most controversial man on the
internet viewed billions of times now
banned from every major platform I'll
talk exclusively to Andrew Tate
[Music]
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
good evening from London and welcome to
Petersburg nonsense to the Conservative
Party Conference was supposed to be a
Victory Parade the new prime minister
Liz truss is turning into something more
like a Barb brawl speeches by the Home
Secretary and foreign secretary today
should have put the migrant crisis in
Ukraine's war on Center Stage instead
yet again is squabbling in the
conservative party that everyone's
talking about trust was badly bruised by
the tax cut fast of her own making this
morning she did what all in battle PMS
do she put on a hard hat and then
through her Chancellor firmly under the
trust bus
you made clear that it was your
chancellor who made the decision in the
first place about scrapping the top race
attacks
Wally would you in future leave big
decisions to him again when he got such
an important early decision rocks
but what we've done is we have listened
to what people said on this issue
viewers will have heard you not answer
the question about whether you trust
your Chancellor given the scale of the
mistake that you say he made
are you sure you don't want to say you
trust your Chancellor
I work very very closely with my chance
so we're very focused on getting the
economy growing and that's what people
in Britain want yes well they still
haven't said you trust your Chancellor
how hard can it be to say you trust your
own Chancellor unless you don't trust
him for his part quasi quateng blames
the queen bizarrely insisting that the
high pressure of delivering a budget so
soon after Her Majesty's funeral led to
all the mistakes
let's face it quasi-quarting is not long
for this world as Chancellor and nor I
suspect will this trust me if she can't
restore control of her own team let's do
one month into the job and our own
party's conference Penny Morton and two
other cabinet ministers today brazenly
attacked her plans to cut benefits Home
Secretary said the provinces of the
victim of a coup with no apparent
understanding of what a coup is this is
what happens when you scrape past the
bottom of the barrel
you get chaos you get incompetence and
you get this the new health secretary
Teresa coffee couldn't even keep her
audience away look how many of them are
asleep literally most of them are asleep
that she would send me to sleep but this
is their own conference these people
have paid to be there look at it
wakey wakey
unbelievable these are the people of
course who voted in this trust
who then put quasi-quarting in the
treasury and now look at it total chaos
I said at the start of September when I
came back for this Brave New World of
Liz truss we need his strong leadership
what have we got complete and utter
rudderless chaos
and the victims as always are we the
British public
well right now the conservative party
looks ungovernable and more warranty for
the rest of us it looks well
increasingly incapable of governing at
all joining me now is political
journalist Avis and Tina taught to be
contributor Esther Krakow I talked to be
political educate McCann and the time
political sketch writer Quentin Letts uh
well those two have The Misfortune of
Being at the Tory Party Conference
quentinlets um I've been waiting all day
to hear what you making this because it
seems to me from a sketchwriter point of
view Christmas has come months early
well I don't know actually I hate
conferences peers and why aren't you
here by the way you're neglecting your
duties you coward
um uh this conference has been very it's
been very downbeat initially but today
actually solo braveman the new Home
Secretary got them on their feet for the
first uh time really and made a
traditional old-fashioned Dory Home
Secretary uh Speech but earlier it was a
snoozefest it has been a snoozefest as
you were showing earlier with Therese
coffee speech and um I was one of those
who drifted off I had to confess I'd had
a couple of pints at lunchtime and it
gets to you that sort of thing
um but uh they are they're in a terrible
place at the moment but things happen in
politics things can change do you
remember
um when Theresa May was 20 points ahead
in the opinion polls she was going to be
strong and stable she was going to be
our prime minister for 10 years Boris
was going to be our prime minister for
10 years and you know things change
things go up and down and they're having
a terrible but terribly bad time is Liz
truss going to be our prime minister for
10 weeks would be my question don't ask
me
you're supposed to be the guy who knows
these things
well I don't know I know nothing I know
nothing none of us knows anything I
think it's very difficult very difficult
to get rid of her so fast
um and also you know who where would
they turn to next would they go for
Rishi soon like I don't think so because
he didn't win the leadership election
would they bring back Boris that might
actually work well they're not going to
bring back Boris
he had a mandate from the public right
well mentioned Richie sunac I mean he
did accurately predict all this Mayhem
if this trust was to win and carry
through the promises she made in the
leadership campaign so actually why not
Rishi sooner given he seemed to be the
only one who realized the dangers of
what she was spouting
well certainly some of the chaos the
market chaos which you seem like did
warn about but the chaos here at
conference the political chaos I mean I
don't think anybody predicted that it
would be like this you've got cabinet
members basically slagging each other
off here at conference just a couple of
weeks into a brand new government it's
not a great place to be but the question
of issue cynic I mean what it actually
illuminates peers on a kind of more
serious point I suppose is the gods that
now exists between the Parliamentary
party the Tories in Westminster and the
party itself the membership who are all
here at conference because they're the
ones who wanted list trust they're the
ones who like her they backed her they
supported her the Parliamentary party
didn't really they wanted Mishi sunak
but again wish you soon like never
played that well with the membership
which of course is why he didn't win and
that golf is a problem because when you
come to conference and people want to
hear exciting new policies there's a
disagreement there are some in the
cabinet who are saying we should do this
there are others who say we definitely
shouldn't and list trust needs to come
through the middle and bring everybody
together and as we've seen so far at
conference that's been pretty difficult
well Quentin the the journalist who
actually started all this in a way Noah
Hoffman from the Sun who was the
journalist who just joined the Sun and
revealed the Scandal which led to
boris's terrible uh treatment of the
scand which led to his his departure she
tweeted earlier which I thought was that
I I've been far bit for me to suggest
she might be a better uh sketchwriter
going forward but she said this Tory
conference is so amazingly messy I still
can't believe it's real ministers going
completely Rogue MP's barely here
they're still throwing shade left right
and Center Tory members Downing
champagne while half laughing half
crying were all effed it's wild That's
my kind of paragraph
[Music]
well MPS never come to party conferences
if their labor I mean that very very few
MPS like going to party conferences
labor live Dem or tourists so that is
nothing new there uh people getting
tipsy at party conferences it has been
known Morgan to happen I'm afraid I
think I've got Tipsy with you
and I I I have to say I remember the Ian
Duncan Smith years the party conferences
uh they were ghastly events uh they were
pretty bad in Teresa May's time and this
one is just another terrible Party
Conference
to be serious Quentin for a moment you
and I have had enough time in this
political arena for more decades than we
would care to mention to smell the
stench of political Death Around the
party this all has a massive whiff of
political death like there's a sea
change going on which will lead
inexorably to a kierstama labor
government at the next election can you
see any way that they turned this round
now
well my I go back to my first answer
here's although I was being joking I was
being serious as well you can never tell
what is going to happen in politics and
it certainly does have the smell of
rotting fish at the moment but you know
things can happen Putin can can get
toppled the British economy can bounce a
bit and then then mistrust could turn
around and say actually I wasn't so
stupid after all and maybe the more uh
time there is the more time she's given
if she gets that time she might not then
things time can bring its own surprise
all right okay I mean I think the
calculation as always for conservative
MPS will be are they going to keep their
jobs in the upcoming election and the
clock is ticking these polls are so
catastrophic at the moment that many
many many conservative MPS will be out
of a job if this carries on so if she
doesn't turn this round and the polls
don't turn round I reckon we get to
Christmas and they're going to start
thinking we've got to get rid of it
oh they already know that they may not
have a job in a couple of years
well here you know even ministers
government ministers newly appointed
ones will say to you oh I'll lose my
seat I won't say that ever outwardly so
they'll never admit to it in public but
they know behind the scenes that they
probably will lose their seat you're
right that there is that sense of change
and momentum towards something else but
it that question about Labor that's the
problem so kirst armor as a labor leader
doesn't attract people's votes people's
votes May well bleed that way because
ultimately they don't want to vote
conservative anymore but that's a very
different thing it's not predictable
it's not as solid and so that's the kind
of difficulty here to predict what
happens next yes the conservatives are
all a bit weirdly kind of happy they
keep going around asking each other you
know how do you feel it's a bit mad
isn't it and they say oh we'll lose our
jobs and it's all going to be awful but
at the end of the day that doesn't
necessarily mean they are going to lose
their jobs there could still be a
conservative win at the next election it
might not be a big one but I wouldn't
say that labor are over the line yet and
the other thing is the voters really
don't like having their votes taken for
granted be it by government as we've
seen or by an opposition or by the media
yeah saying that this is a a foregone
conclusion yeah and uh you know you you
haven't got a chance yeah so I'm just
hesitant this far out from a general
election to be quite so assertive as you
sometimes are
I think uh I think Charleston quieting a
toast personally but we'll see I was
right about Boris as Kate knows to her
financial cost and I suspect I'll be
right again but thank you both very much
and I enjoy the double act tonight we
may have to reenact this uh but Quentin
I can see you're jumping at the bit to
go down to the bar so off you go uh and
Kate I mean you'll be carrying on
working
thank you both very much indeed
uh now look uh we're not going to go to
The Economist Professor Danny Blanche
flower now Mr Blanche flower uh you're
in New Hampshire I understand
um what are you feeling over there
looking at this because you worked for
the the bank of England
um you've been in these positions before
of economic crisis what do you think of
what's going on here
well I think you said the party is in
chaos the country's in chaos I'm an
economist I think what started this off
was it put markets into chaos and I
wrote a column in July and I said I'm
afraid Liz stupid is behaving as Mrs
stupid and at some point she has to
return to being Mrs sensible and the pre
and the permanent secretary at the
treasury will probably tell her of
sensible things to do well on day one
they shot the messenger and it was quite
clear that the markets were not going to
like this and they plowed on so I think
your commentators were interesting in
the sense that they talked about well
maybe this will turn around I think in
terms of the economics Pandora's Box has
been opened this is a complete disaster
and actually I think there's a
conference that's actually probably even
more important than the Tory party which
is next week and next week has the
meeting of the IMF in Washington DC and
I suspect you're going to hear
cataclysmic come commentary from from
Finance ministers all around the world
and they're going to come and
journalists are going to come back to
trust and quartang and say look what
you've done you've messed up the world
so I think it's catastrophic I call it
the economics of pandemonium but um I
just don't think there's any turning
back peers I think I think this is this
is now we're in the end game yeah I I do
feel it just unraveled very very quick
because I think that it's not just
economic chaos it's now political I
agree with open influences amongst
cabinet ministers all contradicting each
other there's no Collective
responsibility there's no sense of
leadership from this trust or control
over her own cabinet even let alone the
economy or the country right and when
you have a rud on this leader like this
my experience is it normally falls apart
very quickly
well I agree with that I agree with that
and you've talked about the politics but
I want to go to the to the economics I
mean the truth is in the economics one
hour is a really long time I mean we
have to look back at things that we've
never seen we saw Pension funds nearly
being closed down on Monday we saw
mortgage mortgage companies were not
even been able to price products so I do
think that but I think now if it's a
it's we're so I mean maybe we have to
use the word the death spiral I mean
we're literally at the point now where
the markets are sitting on a knife edge
and I've sat there long and hard trying
to think well if you know if Piers
Morgan and I were the with a Chancellor
in the and the government of the bank of
England what could we do and I think the
answer is it's very very hard to see I
mean if she's just scrapped everything I
don't think that works so I think the
economics is now so lost that the
political chaos and all the rest of it
um have kind of combined together and
the ultimate one we have to think of
think about the housing market Pierce so
now now this 1.6 million people who are
going to see their mortgages tick up
we've got all these youngsters who were
trying to buy a new house and can't so
this is a this is a disaster coming and
what's the bank of England going to have
to do it's gonna have to raise rates so
now you have to think the woman on the
Mile End Road Omnibus is going to stand
up and say what about me and a mile down
the road the bankers are getting extra
bonuses so I think I think everything
you said I agree with but I want to add
to it that I think what will drive
everything will be the economics because
now now he I mean you okay he he does
the he says I'm going to scrap the 45
rate but what about all the other stuff
this is these are unfunded you say I'm
going to wait till November the 23rd you
can't wait till Friday right I totally
agree don't you agree with that well I
do but thank you for that very cheery
assessment I think that's gonna uh I'm
afraid that the worst thing about it is
I kind of agree with you I think from an
economic point of view everyone I've
talked to who knows about economics
thinks this has been a total basket case
and it's staggering to me the
conservative party which has always
historically prided itself of being the
party of economic competence has now
been exposed as so unbelievably
incompetent with the economy but that's
where we are uh Professor thank you very
much for leaving the quest yes very much
of course thank you the final word to
you I was going to say the question yeah
the final question I think you have to
ask people is what are you going to do
to calm this all down I mean you're
gonna have the chance okay all of this
stuff but what are you going to do to
calm everything down and he has no clue
so that's the killer question yeah it is
you can't stop it can you you can't
Professor I'm afraid I agree with you
which is not what I wanted to do because
it's so doomlin but I agree no thank you
very much for joining me I appreciate it
of course thanks for having me quick
word with my Pat we'll come back for
more after the break but as to your
reaction to all this because I mean you
hear a topic Anonymous who was literally
on the bank of England's monetary policy
committee for three years saying
basically this is economic apocalypse I
mean I think it's very clear that
listross is dealing with a very let's
say inexperienced media team because the
biggest because I've spoken to people
that said the biggest issue was the lack
of communication the markets weren't
expecting this so you're naturally they
will get spooked and then there were
questions around obviously describing
the top grade of tax money like why
didn't you raise the personal allowance
threshold so people on Lower incomes can
actually keep more of their money as
opposed to people that only need to keep
more of their money getting a tax break
because if you if you balance the books
it'll roughly be about the same if you
pushed up the personal tax allowance so
I think that's the biggest issue is the
lack of communication so now
communication moving forward is key you
need to rein in your cabinet members
that are trying to make a name for
themselves well they've all gone wrong
exactly I mean where is the whip but
it's because they're doing this because
she herself doesn't Inspire confidence I
said if Richie sunak won the leadership
the Tories are definitely lost and I
think the reason why conservative versus
took the chance with this is because
they felt that she would at least come
up with something yeah you see I don't
actually agree with that because I think
Rishi is economically competent and I
think he's not he's not politically sexy
well he doesn't attract first we're now
seeing what political space looks like
uh
let me bring you in here I mean it's an
interesting thing because if you
actually talk to some people about it
they say look some of the policy stuff
obviously applies right the way down the
line to the poorest people in the
community but it's all been sold Optics
wise as taking care of Bankers the
wealthier sections of of the of society
in a sparing the windfall tax but energy
covers and so on what do you think you
do take the Michael a little bit when
you say that they are economically
literate I mean over the last 12 years
we've experienced austerity which killed
130 000 people and now in another
economic crisis the Tories have been in
power for 12 years and all we've
experienced is stagnation but I just
want to pick up on something you said
about her cabinet ministers all going
rogue you know who that reminds me of is
Margaret Thatcher so she's got the
chance now to actually kick out everyone
in her cabinet and start afresh the
problem is Margaret Thatcher famously
was this the ladies not for turning it
was a big speech and that was her her
thing that she just didn't go back on
policy however tough it was however hard
it played out what you're seeing with
this trust at the very first hurdle the
first time that her opponents inside her
own party come for her led by Michael
Gove she wilts and she turns and she
does a U-turn I think that to me that to
me is shockingly weak yeah even if she
had to do it it's politically it is I
think lost a lot of the confidence of
natural Tory voters because like how can
we take you seriously enough I agree
let's take a short break we come back
and talk about uh well it's not a
braveman tonight has been talking about
uh migration and Asylum Seekers pretty
controversial stuff coming from the new
Home Secretary we'll talk about that
after the break
and I first look at my students
interview with possibly the most hated
and controversial man on the internet
Andrew Tate I'm Gonna Miss This
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to Perry's organized
censored a poll earlier today which was
from Redfield Wilton on the 3rd to 4th
of October Westminster voting intention
by the red wall labor 61 up 12
conservative 23 down 11.
unbelievable what is going on with this
polling and this is Wipeout territory
for the conservatives in the red wall
but I suspect in many other territories
if they don't get their ad together well
let's turn to migration more than 30 000
migrants have crossed the English
Channel in small boats this year of
course all illegally or most of them
already surpassing last year's record
Naval patrols don't stand the tide
neither surprisingly descending 55
million pounds to France and living it
with them and with the government's
faster called Rwanda policy minor legal
challenges I'm secretary sweller
Braverman used her conference speech and
Aid to try to assure delegates that
she'll be the one to get a group of this
if you deliberately enter the United
Kingdom illegally from a safe country
you should be swiftly returned to your
home country or relocated to Rwanda that
is where your Asylum claim will be
considered well of course all very tough
talk we've heard it of course a million
times you went on to say she wants net
migration down to the tens of thousands
we've heard that phrase for a decade as
far as I'm aware joining me now is
leader of the Heritage party David
Curtin along with Ava and Esters David
Kern what do you make of swella
bravaman's plans today it sounds like a
good speech I mean she ticked all the
boxes for her audience in the
conservative any difference to pretty
Patel well that's the thing you know
they've been promising for 12 years and
they're going to get a grip of migration
illegal migration bring the numbers down
to the tens of thousands and I think
with Sue Ella Braven we're just hearing
the same thing that we've heard from
Theresa May and pretty Patel she's gone
a little bit further with some of the
promises that she's made you know we're
going to deport people back to their
home countries or to Rwanda but then at
the end of the speech which was and
shine on that she says but there's not
much I can do about it now I'm going to
be honest I'm going to take time because
there's all these people who are against
us and human rights lawyers and so on we
need we can't really deal with that
right now so Ava I guess I mean look on
the left the view is these are a bunch
of right-wing head bangers and it's all
disgusting and disgraceful but there is
a reality check a number of people
coming over on these boats across the
channel is breaking all records it
appears to be getting completely out of
control people are dying in the process
which is awful what do we do about it as
a country yeah but you need people to
believe that so that you can put out
this kind of fluff well the numbers
don't like believe that we're being
invaded and we're not and they're not
migrants they're refugees I spend a lot
of they're not all refugees I spend a
lot of time in Calais and a lot of these
people are from Afghanistan which we
have just pulled out of and a lot it
turned out also from Albania who are
economically have you been have you been
to Calais I haven't seen one Albanian
down there but I do see a lot of Iraqis
I see a lot of the one day you spend
time one day one day do you know how
much time I spent on this I will take
you I will take you down to Cali and you
can see that all of this is far but the
thing is
you treat all of them as Asylum Seekers
absolutely and I tell you why you
haven't done it I tell you why you have
to process them here because we don't
have a system where you can apply from
abroad it doesn't exist if you are an
Afghan right now again the Arab system
is closed
I think it should be twofold right you
should have you should because you have
un channels that allows Ukrainian
refugees to come to the UK for instance
you should open that up to various um
other parts of the world but that that
requires dedicating government resources
to that but I'm sorry to pretend like
these people are just refugees when they
destroy a lot of their documentation
upon Landing in the UK and um
when we get over generalizing about any
of this we make mistakes they're not all
legitimate refugees or Asylum Seekers
and they're not and they're not all
economic migrants trying it on and
they're not all throwing their phones in
museum and not all dodging their
paperwork there's a mixed bag of people
coming in some of whom as Ava rightly
says are from war-torn countries some
from Autumn countries where we started
the wars like Iraq for example so my
question is where is where is the heart
and soul of this country when it comes
to Asylum refugees and where is the more
perhaps hard-hearted head saying we
can't let this channel migration on
these small boats continue I think the
heart and soul should be with women and
children who actually go through
official channels of which there should
be more of to come to the UK I'm sorry
the fact is a young able-bodied men
of the way so they can bring their
families
my father if we were in trouble my dad
would go and then he would bring me and
myself
you'll send your wife and child to
safety first before they don't know it
does safe because they're going with
Souls
man they're coming from a safe country
they're coming from France or Belgium
that's a safe country so they're
actually shopping around in the country
where they have the best benefits
they would claim asylum in the first
safe country you can get to if you're
running for your life you'd be running
for your life with your family
during World War II during the Holocaust
right after which so Winston Churchill's
complaining it's not it's the refugee of
course is happening you know in Eastern
Europe obviously in France in Germany
this is not happening if France is not
undergoing a holocaust at the moment so
anyone who's coming through France
is shopping for the best benefit that's
a totally differences that was 80 years
ago what's happening now is that people
coming from the safe country are coming
to another safe country and they
shouldn't be they're not genuine the
language
hostile to people of Muslim faith is a
safe country it's not safe
in the country
they banned like they banned the burka
they banned the burger
the problem is it seems to me again the
problem I have is generalization when
you're sweeping you say look these are
all legitimate refugees that is not true
when other side says they're all
economic migrants trying it on
military-aged men that's not true either
right the truth is it's more complicated
but the reality of the problem is it's
getting worse not better and nobody
seems to have a good idea what to do
about specifically these boats coming
over the channel a great risk to people
in there driven by these people
traffickers so I just simply when I talk
to people on the left I said well what
is your answer to I give you it right I
can't just be to let everybody else you
can't have an open border let me give
you a Pez macron proposed that we put a
post over in Calais where we would be
able to process people and the reason
that was thrown out by Boris Johnson
pretty Patel was because they argued it
would be a pull factor but you can't say
you need to get processed before coming
to the UK and then not offer a
processing center so that's what I would
suggest I actually I would go further I
agree with that and I would go further I
would say you have to dedicate you
actually have to dedicate a lot more
resources and work a lot more closely
with the French and Belgian governments
Because the actual problem is once they
cross the channel you need to stop them
at peak hours before they're even able
to do that and that actually requires
deeper cooperation David let me ask you
who would you let in what would your
criteria be genuine Asylum Seekers who
this is the first thing well I mean
because someone coming from France they
shouldn't come to the country they
shouldn't come to the uh
because they've been in France doesn't
mean they can't come to drive but the
thing is I wouldn't allow anyone who's
coming from France to claim Asylum here
because we've got to consider the facts
on this country this is one of the most
dense
it's putting pressure on housing we
don't have as bigger population as
France and the reality is a lot of these
people have come to France from on
war-torn countries right I know some of
them personally myself who've come over
on the boat and made great you know
lives for themselves in our country
working as covid Ward cleaners in the
pandemic for example the filmmaker that
I've interviewed many times on this show
so the point being a lot of them come to
France from war countries so they are
legitimate Asylum Seekers and refugees
who may have family in that case did in
our country we surely have a moral
Ginger to take those people I don't
think we do I mean we have a moral duty
to take you know some people and we've
got a great hit so they can only come if
they come direct from a war zone well
that's normally the case how do they get
here well we do we do have schemes to
take things
but we also we're full as a country I
mean at the moment all the people coming
across the channel they're going into
hotels I mean there's there's no housing
there's no actual housing for people to
go in well people in this country who
want a council home around on the list
for 10 25 years so we're really out of
space I think the truth we can one thing
we can all agree the current system
doesn't work right it just doesn't work
I don't think rwanda's ever going to
work off the ground so they they've got
to come up with a plan and this is where
the problem with the list trust
government is that her plans unravel
very quickly yeah if you do u-turns on
big plans how can we trust you on things
like this to fix it in the way that they
keep saying they're going to we will see
thank you for joining us uh appreciate
it some of you are staying some are
being shipped out and we back after the
break we're going to talk about a guy
called Andrew Tate if you don't know
about him well you're in the minority he
was the most Googled human being in the
world a few months ago
I'm saying that an 18 or a 19 year old
woman would be more desired 25 year old
woman Auntie 25 year old women we can
argue but not misogynistic well that's
massage no no no it's not being anti any
woman at all not when I'm not what I'm
saying that women are beautiful and
attractive at a certain age
gospel debate digital censorship with
the woman who defends Andrew Tate
there she is
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Andrew Tate's the most famous man you've
probably never heard of but the chances
are your children will have videos of
Tate have been doing billions of Times
online he's got an enormous following
amongst the young men and this is often
scandalous views about women that have
made him notorious across the World
Views like this
so I think my sister is my her husband's
property yes when a bride is walking
down the aisle to marry the groom the
father walks next to her and gives her
away true or false takes opinions on
mental illness are equally controversial
for bad in the middle of the night when
you hear a noise and you believe in
ghosts now you're afraid but if you
don't believe in ghosts that's the wind
then you go back to see you give the
ghost power by believing
well there's some every major social
media platform band Tate amid a global
backlash concerns about his influence on
the young people who watch him but
copies of his videos are still shared
millions of times every day this show is
called uncensored what are the
challenges views directly so he flew
from Romania to sit here in this studio
and the full explosive interview as
later this week here's a bit of what's
has come
do you respect women absolutely why
wouldn't I do you think the 18 19 year
old woman are more attractive than 25
year old woman I think there's
Attractive people uh that's that's a
loaded question I don't know it's not
really is it I I can't know why I'm
asking of course I do but I can't sit
here and so the benefit of you is you
don't know why I'm asking you said this
in general this is also one of the
reasons men find youth attractive you
want to blow up the internet or block
the internet write a thing now the
reason 18 and 19 year olds are more
attractive than 25 year olds is because
they've been through less dick people
say oh you can't say that but yes I can
a 19 year old is more attractive than 26
year old woman and I'll tell you why
because that 26 year old has talked to
more guys been to the club more times
being effed and dumped more times more
arguments more mass more for me to clean
up that is misogyny why because you are
encouraging a mindset about 25 year old
women that makes them stand out to be
infinitely less desirable than 18 19
year olds and having effectively been
having too much sex to be taken in a
more respectful way that would well
firstly even if that was the case that
wouldn't be misogyny what did you mean
by what you said that's not misogyny
because it's not anti-women I'm saying
that an 18 or a 19 year old woman would
be more desired 25 year old woman
anti-25 year old women we can argue but
not misogynistic no no no it's not being
anti-any woman at all is misogynistic
not when I'm not what I'm saying that
women are beautiful and attractive at a
certain age and saying the ages you're
saying 1890s are more attractive than 21
other than ageist perhaps but
misogynistic absolutely but you just
accepted it was misogyny no I didn't you
said it was montessorging I'm telling
you no it's not but if a 26 year old
woman is watching this and has heard
those comments would you just say to her
look I'm sorry I shouldn't have said
that no I won't I will say that I am
sorry that that offends you however
there's a large contingent of the world
it doesn't mean you're sorry no I'm not
sorry that's the point I'm making I'm
sorry if that offends you however
there's a large contingent of the world
that believed that and I was mediating
for a conversation parts of the world
that believed that about 26 year old
women are parts of the world where women
are not allowed out on their own that's
your that's a conversation wear full
buckets well that's a conversation
they're not allowed to drive cars that's
nothing to do with it but is that the
kind of world for a woman I was
mediating I was mediating a conversation
I'm asking you what you think I I don't
live in a country where that happens
you're using that as the excuse for why
you're not sorry for saying it there are
parts of the world but this is fine my
question to you is well do you think
it's fine I don't think it's fine I live
in a world where you don't think it's
fine my the reason this isn't that hard
Andrew you can see me say beers you know
what with the benefit of hindsight I
wish I hadn't said it like that and if a
26 year old woman's watching I'm sorry I
said that because that actually is
blatantly misogynist and even though
that's the view held by other parts of
the world it's not a view I share now I
would respect you more if you said that
yeah and if you try and say Well it said
in other parts of the world so I'm not
sorry I think that doesn't tell me what
you think then you need to understand
why my content existed in the first
place my content existed because I tried
my very hardest to be an absolute not a
realist especially with uncomfortable
truths I was pointing out that very
uncomfortable is that a truth it's an
uncomfortable truth in many parts of the
world it's not a proof that I'm happy
about an inquest this week found that
the 14 year old girl Molly Russell died
from an active self-harm or suffering
from depression and the negative effects
of online content the coroner said she
was exposed to material that may have
influenced her in a negative way and in
addition I started this depression and
become a much more serious depressive
illness and she's very sadly took her
life that's that's absolutely disgusting
right her father's terrible her father's
campaign for better protections it gets
potentially dangerous the social media
algorithms right it says that the
particularly graphic content you saw
romanticized acts of self-harm
normalized her condition and focused on
a limited and irrational view without
any counterbalance of normality
first of all what is your response to
that nothing to do with you yes that's
the first thing yeah it is nothing to do
with me the fact that a 14 year old girl
took her life is truly sad the world we
live in today is
the world we live in the fact that
something like that happened is almost
mind-blowing to me that's truly that's
truly sad I actually feel sad and sad to
see something like that what has come
clear to me in the interview is that a
lot of things you say you wouldn't say
now that you've said before but that's
it differently yeah right so to me
that's an acceptance
not just that you want to get back on
platforms because maybe that was one of
the reasons you were no platform but
you've recognized and understood the
potential harm to the wrong kind of
impressionable mind
by some of the things you've said would
that be fair I think that's 80 fair I
recognize and understand that with
massive Fame
you have to be more careful about being
misconstrued like I said earlier one
percent of people misunderstanding you
doesn't matter with a small audience it
matters with a very large audience with
power comes responsibility I still
believe the things I say I do not want
to be a negative Force for the world I
also understand that I am a man who's
lived a very difficult nuanced life and
I am capable of making nuanced points
that may be misunderstood by teenagers
however that can be said about anybody
and everything every opinion online can
be misunderstood by children trying to
protect children from the Internet is a
very interesting subject in and of
itself because I would argue that eighty
percent of the content on the Internet
is can be negative or detrimental to a
young mind that doesn't understand the
world
so interesting early preview there in my
interview with Andrew Tate I could say
very controversial guys banned from all
social media but I believe in giving
people a chance to have their say and
hold them to account you want to do with
it but at what point does Free Speech
become hate speech at one point does
someone like him deserve or not deserve
to be de-platformed from all social
media we'll debate that after the break
with a woman who defends Andrew Tate and
with the journalist who sat with him and
raised similar thoughts I think is ideal
which is I'm quite sure where that line
is or whether he did in fact cross it he
back after the break
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
from social media with videos about many
women but when exactly does Free Speech
become hate speech and who should get to
decide that joining me now are political
journalist Ava 17 and talk to the
contributor Esther Krakow author and
podcaster and friend of Andrew Tate Leia
hailpern and Times columnist Hugo Rifkin
Hugo let me start with you thank you for
joining the show original big times
interview
um with this guy Andrew Tate I found it
very interesting because I knew I was
going to interview him on television uh
shortly afterwards and what I was struck
by was that although you were pretty
outraged by some of the stuff he said
and done and found it personally pretty
offensive you you didn't really seem to
be able to conclude that he'd really
crossed a line that deserved the
punishment he's received in terms of
social media Wipeout would that be a
fair categorization
yes I wasn't convinced because I'm not
look because I'm not quite sure what
debate we're having here it seems are
given to me that there would be no place
for Andrew Tate on a on a normal
conventional
um media Outlet they're not going to
give him your show they're not going to
give him my show on times radio that
wouldn't happen but it raises the
question of whether we think that these
tech companies Instagram Facebook
companies like that ought to be being
held to the same standards as
traditional media if we think they
should be then obviously he has no place
in them if we think they're actually
more of a a much more free Arena where
things that we might find in other
places unacceptable are in fact
acceptable there then it becomes a whole
different debate and that's the debate
we haven't quite settled I think right
because I mean to me it's not when Trump
got removed from Twitter and Facebook
and so on if you're going to let the
Ayatollah of Iran continue to have
active accounts on these platforms I
don't see the consistency in Banning a
president of the United States or indeed
someone like Andrew Tate
yeah I mean that's that's uh that's
quite fair you've also got to accept
that look huge numbers of people wanted
to watch him huge numbers of people
wanted to listen to him he's he's very
very good at what he what he does in an
earlier age there were people at Andrew
Tate who put out cassettes and CDs over
on you know various forms of of Pirate
Radio they had huge audiences the
audiences are much much Huger now and
they are and much less policed he has
they have much greater inroads people
like Tay into into teenagers for example
so it raises whole new questions whole
new issues I'm not always convinced that
just Banning them is quite the right
answer but then I'm not sure I quite
like to be making that call myself right
I think that's a really good point uh
Leia Halburn uh you're in Miami you know
Andrew Tay you've been to his home in
Romania uh you know his brother
um what kind of guy is he I mean many
people who don't know much about him or
hear some of the stuff he's been saying
which I play to him and challenge him on
in the interview and they'll be
horrified but what do you think
he's an incredibly intelligent man
um I think what he's doing is very
important right now there's a huge war
on masculinity and men don't really have
any kind of role model that they can
look up to
um Andrew has been very kind and very
generous with me um like I said I know
him personally also known from a
business standpoint
um I've spent time with him one-on-one
I've never felt uncomfortable he's never
been inappropriate with me um a lot of
people accuse him of misogyny he's never
been misogynistic towards me and I think
what he's doing is incredibly important
okay Ava Santina your view of this I
mean just from The Exchange we just put
a preview of where he says he prefers 18
19 year old women to 25 year olds I
think I think you're 25 aren't you
um but you know when he generalizes
about 25 year old women in the really I
thought pretty repulsive manner that he
did in public uh I think that is
misogyny actually because he's branding
a whole category of women in a very
offensive way I think it's close to
misogyny I think it's actually more
looking at women as a objectively sexual
objects which inherently is misogynistic
but it's looking for Purity in women
what he is essentially saying between
those lines is that he wants some sort
of virginal woman maybe that's why he
takes this girl seriously I don't know
but I mean it kind of sounds a little
bit like on the other side he's allowed
to I mean he can have these views does
anything that he say says all the stuff
that you've seen with him does it cross
a line where he deserves to be expunged
from all social media to be banished
from the internet when you you've got to
look at the reaction that came off that
so the people who were due cutting his
videos or the people who were spreading
his messages when you've got 15 year old
boys espousing these sort of views where
you're talking about women in purely
sexual terms and that has come from
Andrew Tate and that's where the problem
is what do you think I don't I don't
actually think that's a very fair
assessment he didn't say oh I I just I
only date 19 years I prefer he was
making the point and he could have
phrased it better absolutely but he's
saying she did concede that yeah but the
point he's making is and he's a very
intelligent guy like Leo was saying so
he knows what he's doing when he's
saying that obviously he's got a massive
reaction from it so clearly it's worked
but the point is you know he's saying
that younger women who have had less
experience with men in general are more
desirable because they don't come with a
certain amount of baggage now you could
say they're women that are more
experienced that come with less baggage
because they know what they want or
they're more mature but my view is they
shouldn't be talking about women in that
generalized way at all of any age I know
a lot of 25 year old women in my time
they're all very different it's like the
idea that you bracket them all in this
revolting way which he did which is just
a lad in the nightclub kind of way it's
fine but that's I do it with a big
following I think is a malevolent and
what is implied there is their sexual
history that is what he's talking about
yeah but there are women that are 18
that have a more elaborate sexual
history
time with him for your big interview for
the times what did you actually make of
him by the end when you came away what
did you think of him
oh we've gone very well but then we were
two men sitting in his cigar room
bantering you know we had a good we had
a good chat and a very honest chat I
mean we had a very similar conversation
to the conversation you're having at the
moment I think in different
circumstances I wouldn't have liked to
introduce them to my wife I wouldn't
like to have to hang out with him with
my female friends I think that'd be
intensely uncomfortable but I noticed
the way that at the moment what we're
doing we're debating whether whether or
not he's nice whether or not the things
he thinks are nice or right what we're
not debating is whether or not they
should be allowed right and I think I'm
slightly worries me that we've drifted
into thinking those are the same debates
I agree when did we already become the
moral Arbiters for whether people should
be a lot of social media platform I mean
let me go back to Leia I mean to me you
might find Andrew Tate's views offensive
unsavory misogynist as I did on some
occasions with him although he and he
made some concessions in the interview
I'm not sure by the end that I concluded
he'd done anything really so heinous he
deserved the punishment he's got that
was my real conclusion
yeah I don't think he said anything
wrong I think all he's doing is talking
about reality and I don't think it's
misogynistic to say you prefer a woman
that's 18 versus 25. it's literally just
a sexual preference it's the same reason
I don't think that's the misogyny I had
this argument with my sons though when
they saw the clip the misogyny isn't
that he has a preference for girls of 18
19 25. the misogyny is in the way he
talks about every woman who's 24. as if
they're all the same and they've all
been through this Audrey background
which he finds so distasteful that's
obviously ludicrous well
I think I think he speaks with a lot of
hyperbole his goal was to go viral
obviously as Esther mentioned not all 25
year old women have been sleeping with
every single man that they meet in the
nightclub so there's always exceptions
but I just think in general a 25 year
old woman obviously has had more
experience than an 18 year old woman and
some men prefer that some men don't like
that and I think that's completely fine
I think what's what really scares me is
the censorship that we see online on
Twitter there's actually porn on Twitter
you have terrorists on Twitter and yet a
man who's just talking about reality and
the real dynamics between them and you
know what I gotta say I have to say Leia
I think you make a good point I think
there are the Taliban have Twitter
accounts the artillery of Iran he's
threatened to wipe out Israel has a
Twitter account you know Donald Trump
doesn't Andrew Tate doesn't why you know
I can't really get a satisfactory
response from these platforms it's a
very interesting debate I think to be
had we're going to run the full
interview with Andrew Tate uh well the
whole thing will appear on YouTube by
the end of the week we're going to run a
good hour of it uh age of the week it is
a fascinating watch I have to say and
you might like him you might hate him
but the real question is should he be
banned thank you to my panel thank you
to Hugo thank you to Leia uh that's it
from me you can as I say see it already
in the week whatever you're up to keep
it on censor good night
[Music]
I'm Julia Hartley Brewer and this is
talk TV I think my most memorable and
proudest moment in journalism of all
these years is actually being on air
during the lockdowns even when I had
covered myself over the last two years
getting people to tell their stories not
just about people who lost love wanted
but people who lost their fundamental
freedoms their children's schooling
their mental health their physical
health their businesses and giving
people the chance to tell their stories
about how it affected them
this is talk TV news
good evening I'm Emily Rose Adams Liz
truss has caused a stir in her own party
as she's refused to guarantee that
she'll increase benefits in line with
inflation and speaking to talk TV's
political editor Kate McCann at the Tory
Party Conference the new prime minister
said she would be doing things
differently to Boris Johnson's
government
meanwhile the Home Secretary Suella
bravaman outlined her plans to tackle
migration calling small boat Channel
Crossings a chronic problem and said
those who make the journey face a ban
from claiming asylum in Britain
and trading in Twitter shares has been
suspended as prices spiked following
reports that Elon Musk will go ahead
with his takeover of the site it's now
thought he'll buy the social media
platform at the original share price
offered months ago
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]